Going to the market can be
hell for Nigerian women
They are often touched,
groped and insulted by men
One woman
has launched #MarketMarch
a protest movement that
wants to stop the harassment
"So many Nigerian feminists unite over their
experience at the market, passing through
most of the major markets in cities in Nigeria
is a traumatizing and terrifying experience.
From when they were children, young girls
and even as adult women.
It's something I expect when I'm going to
the market.
And I decided something needed to be done
about it.
Every citizen has a right to protest."
At the first protest
some men were aggressive
They insulted the women and
threw stones at them
"We must touch,
we must touch!"
"They really do not believe that we should
resist them touching us.
There is a very strong sense of entitlement.
In any possible way you can think of, they
will express it.
Whether they're pulling...
I heard stories where they slapped people
who resisted, where they slapped women who
resisted.
So the problem is entitlement and expressing
that entitlement, depending on the market
man you encounter and how engrained it is
in him."
Damilola says the march
was a success
"So many women are tired, they're frustrated
with their position in society.
And they want better.
They are taking matters into their own hands.
And it's only going to get better from there.
It has started.
The momentum has begun and there is no going
back."